you you and i originally clashed if you
want to call it that
around a topic that you're so engrained
with it's part of your brand
it's bitcoin i'm like everybody else
saying if it works
i should own some but frankly all i've
seen so far is volatility
[Music]
okay pomp you know you have achieved
some formidable success in the youtube
and podcast channels
i want to ask you why you think that
happened because there's a million guys
and their dogs trying to gather
followers and even fewer that can
actually monetize it or build a career
around it
you seem to be doing exactly that how
did it happen just give a
give us give our viewers a little clue
because there's so many of them that
want to do what you've
done already yeah i think there's two
keys to it so one is you got to have
substance behind all of the
kind of content and obviously having
invested quite a bit of money in early
stage startups
and having worked at some of the largest
technology companies i think that gives
me an advantage over somebody who just
kind of rolls out of bed and wants to do
this and then the second thing is just
being
overly authentic like who you see in the
content is exactly who you would meet if
you went to dinner with
me and a group of my friends and i think
that the authenticity plus the substance
really kind of stands out from the
people who are trying to put on a show
or be somebody who they're not on the
internet
so basically that's a nice way of saying
people smell
[ __ ] a mile away if there's one
thing that's happened over the last
decade in social media is that
[ __ ] is just radioactive the minute
you get caught lying
you're basically disconnected from the
whole thing that's your premise right
yeah i think one people have great
[ __ ] detector uh but also two people
gravitate towards
uh those that they trust and the best
way to establish trust is to
admit when you're wrong admit your
mistakes and uh just
own up to the good the bad and
everything in between and so
uh one key is to not [ __ ] people but
also two is to
uh really just be honest um when it
comes to uh the good and the bad and i
think there's a lot of people who maybe
don't [ __ ]
people but they don't show the bad side
so
by doing that it's another form of
[ __ ] it's just not as obvious
well it's interesting let me let me
pursue that a little bit because i have
a lot of investments in a really
interesting industry
the wedding industry which has gone
through a lot of trials and tribulations
since the pandemic hit but it's a
multi-billion dollar industry so i've
seen it from every single side
and it's remarkable that you know i have
when i look at
investments like honey fund which
actually allows for gifting
to wedding registrants i've learned
about weddings because i've been in it
for so long that basically within seven
years
fifty percent of the unions fall apart
not because of infidelity because that's
kind of the theme of honesty you're
talking about
but because of financial stress what
breaks people up
is not screwing around it's money
what do you think about that are you
surprised to hear that stat
yeah well i think just generally there's
a lack of financial education
uh throughout the north uh north america
and so when you have people who are
uneducated about money
it's more likely that they're going to
make stupid mistakes with money
um which causes more stress and as we
know
that financial stress can lead to
everything from divorce to unhappiness
etc
and so it shouldn't be surprising since
we have such a high degree of people who
are uneducated
when it comes to personal finance but i
think what hopefully is happening is
people are realizing that
um they need to get educated but they
also need to
put together a plan and kind of set
expectations right you know i've got a
lot of friends who recently have gotten
married
and i'm always surprised by how many of
them never talked about what their
financial goals were or how much money
each one of them made and where they
wanted to live and what their expenses
on a monthly basis would look like
so it's like anything in life if you
plan well and you stay disciplined
you can have success if you basically
just wing it and you're uneducated then
it shouldn't surprise anyone that you
end up in the uh in a bad spot and
ultimately leads to the end of a
marriage
so let's just on that theme for a second
how would you approach
a significant other that's gone off the
rails in spending that's clearly not in
track with the
you know you get married 24 months later
you're stacking up a ton of debt on your
credit card
and it's all coming from one person not
the other to me that spells trouble
but how would you change it what would
you do how how much risk would you take
with your significant other
to say look you got to stop
yeah i think the first thing is the most
important decision you can make in life
is that significant other right so kind
of choosing well
uh can help you avoid a lot of those
problems uh making sure that you're
aligned with
uh the other individual whether it comes
to how much money you want to make how
you spend it
debt versus no debt all of those kind of
important components of personal finance
so pop you're not a romantic you're
telling you'd rather talk about money
you're on your third date saying look i
really can't consider you for a fourth
because i want to talk about cash i want
to talk about how you spend
i mean is that where you're going to go
with it or what are you talking about
here maybe not on the third date but at
some point before you get married to
somebody uh for the rest of your life
you probably should have that
conversation
and i think ultimately what happens is
uh
again it's an education thing so it's
very rare that you find somebody
uh who is educated when it comes to
finance
and uh and kind of money that also
happens to be
over their head in debt or making really
really bad decisions
everyone likes to splurge everyone likes
to buy things um you know
that they enjoy but there's very few
people that are educated
that do that stuff and so i think that's
kind of the way to solve the problem is
to get people educated
uh about how money works and why uh
personal finance is so important
okay let me pivot you in a completely
different different direction
you you and i originally clashed if you
want to call it that around
a topic that you're so engrained with
it's part of your brand it's bitcoin
and bitcoin has had a resurgence in
interest because it's had a resurgence
in value
it's a very very volatile asset class
and it gets a lot of press
on its way up gets a ton of press when
it has a precipitous downgrade and goes
down
and then nobody hears about it for a
while is is bitcoin really driven by
just emotional enthusiasm of people
around the world saying oh it's on its
way up i'm going to follow it
until it blows up and goes down again
where do you think it fits in the
continuum of holding asset value because
you know i'm going to give you a chance
to talk to institutional investors here
when you think about it
that want to understand are they missing
out on something or is it just another
fad i know and you know i'm
i'm kind of agnostic to it i'm like
everybody else saying if it works
i should own some but frankly all i've
seen so far is volatility
yeah so i think you got to separate
price and value right the price
is just the market that's made by buyers
and sellers when there's more buyers
than sellers the price goes up when
there's more sellers than buyers the
price goes down and that's true of every
asset including bitcoin
the volatility is driven just because
it's such a small market cap
right you know just today it's about a
350 360 billion dollar market cap
that's much much smaller than gold real
estate equities etc
when it comes to value though the
underlying fundamentals have only
continued to get stronger and stronger
over time this is the number of people
using it
the amount of transaction volume on an
annual basis the amount of computing
power
what is really interesting to me about
bitcoin is we're basically watching
public price discovery in real time so
usually what happens is let's take a
public equity for example
uh the public equity uh was a private
equity before
that and there was some level of price
discovery and when it comes out
there's a whole bunch of people that get
in a room and they agree on here is the
price of this asset
and so you have some artificial pricing
and then it gets released into the
market
you see with doordash airbnb others it
gets repriced at a new price by those
public investors
well bitcoin didn't have that kind of
couple of people get in a room in
private and set a price instead we're
watching it happen in real time
and so there's going to be these boom
and bust cycles because the other
component is the investors have been
retail investors
these are not overly sophisticated
professional investors that are managing
billions and billions of dollars
so when you have less algorithmic
trading more retail investors
in public price discovery you're going
to get lots of volatility that's driven
by emotion
so bad headline comes out bitcoin sells
off good headline comes out bitcoin goes
up
i think that that's starting to temper
out a little bit though just because
there are
more professional investors like the
stanley druckenmillers the paul tutor
jones guggenheim fidelity etc coming in
and also you're starting to get some
algorithmic trading and so my guess is
that over a long period of time maybe
five 10 years bitcoin looks very similar
to other assets
the exciting part though is if you can
participate in the price discovery
from where it is today to something
that's much more valuable in the future
obviously the people that are early will
do well
in that price discovery well there's
also another lesson to take from what
you just said
perhaps what's interesting about bitcoin
is the fact that it trades 24 7
in perpetuity and that there's very few
markets that actually have price
discovery going on
all around the world every day
regardless of what else is going on
so maybe what it really speaks to is
having other asset classes like stocks
like bonds trade in the same manner
where there's a market bid
24 7 globally that's not that hard to do
with technology today because we came
out of the stock market
you know a couple hundred years ago with
the idea that you opened for business at
one time and closed later in the day
maybe what bitcoin is telling us is that
we should have liquidity
perpetually in every asset class and
that pure price discovery
because it's always breakfast somewhere
in the world may be the way
of the future and in in a way if that
actually
happens pomp there'll be less demand for
something like a bitcoin would you agree
with that
yeah so i definitely think that having
24 7 365 markets uh is important right
so if you think of the u.s stock market
for example
the u.s stock market is closed more
hours a week than it is open
there's some advantages to that but
there's a lot of downside to it as well
and it's very kind of western world view
of kind of markets and so i think that
now that the
internet allows for accessibility on a
24 7 365
geographically agnostic basis it's
really important to get to kind of
always-on markets
the second piece of this though is i
also think whether the new york stock
exchange
nasdaq or other types of traditional
exchanges move
to that 24 7 model or not it won't
matter because what we're starting to
see emerge is
an entire world or kind of alternative
finance world
where people are basically taking these
stocks off those exchanges
and they're creating tokenized versions
of them so there's an exchange in
singapore right now
that essentially allows you to trade
apple stock 24 7 365.
now it's not the actual apple stock that
is on the us stock market it's a
tokenized version
and so i think that what people
ultimately want in the traditional
markets is they want
exposure to these assets and whether
they get that through actually owning
the shares or they get that through
holding what is essentially a price
proxy i think you're seeing the demand
there and so what we have now is we've
got kind of a face-off is this new
alternative financial system
going to be uh kind of rising in
popularity and capture the
mental energy and financial means of all
of these other people
or will the u.s based exchanges kind of
open up their model and go to a 24 7 365
model
at the end of the day i think that the
people who want that are going to get
serviced
it's just a matter of is it going to be
the incumbents or is it going to be
challengers and i think that's where the
market gets made and where a lot of
opportunity lies
the problem with an idea like that
though is it's a derivative
from the actual asset so you talk about
a singapore exchange having a call or
put on
apple that works until there's massive
volatility in the market and all of a
sudden you get huge spreads between
what those things trade at and what the
actual apple stock is doing
and i think if you're an institutional
investor the value of having 24 7 365
you know liquidity is nowhere near as
valuable as actually having price
discovery on the real asset
when there's tremendous volatility in
the market now that's getting a little
technical but
my issue around these special asset
classes let's drift back to bitcoin
because
it is the granddaddy of all of the
debates going on here
there would be tremendous value in a
currency a digital currency
and every time i talked about this it's
the same topic i look at i look at the
asset value of bitcoin versus the asset
value
of all things traded and bitcoin is
still a nothing burger a giant nothing
burger and the reason i would argue that
that's the case is
you you don't have every institution
willing to play ball with it
but if there was an attempt to either
take bitcoin itself
or some other currency because i think
bitcoin's proven the first mile there's
no question about it
there's global interest in digital
currency but a a digital currency that
could be traded everywhere with the
regulator agreeing to it
and would be agnostic in other words you
could trade it to buy
assets in switzerland traded to buy
assets in france or in england or in the
united states and everybody would take
that digital currency
then you would have something pomp then
you would have something of tremendous
value
because that way i could keep half my
net worth in the digital currency
and just flow and trade and go in and
out of things i could buy groceries i
could buy a house with it
it wouldn't i'd be agnostic to it that
is a vision that's really attractive
versus this tiny little thing that for
some people is an outlier
that in in many ways is not liquid or
not easily liquid
like if i want to buy a million dollars
worth of of bitcoin right now
i got to do a fair amount of work to
pull that off it's not instantaneous
it's getting better i agree but it's not
something that every regulator in every
market
if i just pick big markets like england
like
euro like switzerland like the us like
china like asia
i i can't get consistency with any
single regulator
on endorsing bitcoin for me to actually
do a significant transaction
how are we going to fix that you're a
bitcoin guy i'm giving you a big
opportunity to explain
how we get to the next level so one of
the key things to understand is that
bitcoin's market cap has increased by
about 80 million dollars a day
since its inception which is really
really fast aggressive growth for any
asset
but there's been a lot of price
volatility in between there and so up
until maybe 2019
2020 most of the interest was from
individuals right or very small
organizations it wasn't the large asset
managers
but i think that the macro environment
and the changes that have occurred
especially the quantitative easing and
the interest rate manipulation
uh in 2020 has driven global macro
investors to say where should i put my
capital
and what we're seeing are massive
inflows into bitcoin and it's coming
from some very unique people
so again i mentioned paul tudor jones a
stanley druckenmiller those types of
people i think
are at the forefront or the tip of the
spear when it comes to innovation and
investing but we're also seeing very
conservative organizations like there
are multiple public pensions in the
united states that have invested in this
there's uh mass mutual which is a very
conservative insurance company
that are starting to allocate it's small
dollars to start usually kind of up to
one percent of their assets
uh but i think that that will continue
to increase over time because ultimately
what bitcoin's
hope is right what the promise of
bitcoin is is that it will serve as that
single global currency right it can uh
ascend to global reserve status
and it can be used by anyone regardless
of uh their nationality
uh their language uh or their location
as that single currency
now whether that happens or not is up
for debate there are people speculating
billions and billions of dollars on the
possibility of that occurring but i
agree with you that the opportunity
is there and i think that if an asset
can
rise to that point it will be incredibly
valuable those that
understand bitcoin believe in bitcoin
and hold bitcoin i think believe bitcoin
will do that
but there are plenty of other people who
think it'll be something else and so
we'll see what happens but
i think you've nailed kind of the
opportunity now the question is just who
actually captures that and i think
bitcoiners believe it'll be bitcoin
all right so so help listeners diversify
the risk if you if you just get
intrigued with the idea
of owning digital currency for creation
of wealth over time
why just bitcoin what other ones how you
know i love diversification that's my
whole investment theme i want diversity
i want to mitigate risk
now if i decide yes digital currency i
think i should have
a two percent waiting in my portfolio of
digital currencies
you've been watching this space forever
which ones
why just bitcoin what else what about
ethereum what about all the rest of that
stuff that's in any wallet you look at
yeah so first of all definitely bitcoin
has the network effect it has the brand
awareness
it has majority of the capital uh in the
space
it is kind of like you said the
granddaddy of them all and so if you
kind of think of it as
the blue chip uh bitcoin is definitely
there
now most of the people who only hold
bitcoin the
the kind of hardcore bitcoiners and are
the people who understand monetary
policy etc
they have a belief that bitcoin is going
to become that global reserve currency
so they almost use it as
cash right it is an electronic currency
to them uh and they hold it for that
purpose just like they would hold cash
in their bank account
they hold bitcoin now there are some
people who disagree with that uh belief
system they believe that
uh kind of in your camp that there
should be diversification and so what
we're seeing there is they're starting
to be vehicles in which
uh you can actually go get that
diversification and so um a company that
i'm invested in called bitwise recently
launched a
fund uh that is publicly traded on the
otc market
uh or the otc exchange uh it's just bitw
as the ticker and it gives you exposure
to the top ten
uh crypto assets their market weight
averaged and they're rebalanced on a
frequent basis
and so similar to like an s p 500 type
uh index that gives you exposure to an
industry
this at uh this specific fund uh and
others that are following it will do the
exact same thing
and so i think people have to ask
themselves you know do i want to
basically put
my assets in something that is the most
de-risked out of all of the assets
or do i just want industry-wide
diversified exposure
i don't think you can go wrong with
either one frankly bitcoin in one of
those scenarios is a hundred percent of
the allocation
in the other it's like 85 so bitcoin is
just so dominant compared to everything
else
but i think either one of those options
gets people in the game you get kind of
off zero percent exposure right i keep
saying get off zero
and once you put money into something
you start paying attention you start
learning about it
and i think that's kind of the first
step for people who have heard about
this are intrigued by it and want to
start to get exposure to it
all right let's take a 180 shift let's
talk about next year
now the first on the agenda has to be
the vaccine
in your head where are you at with the
vaccine you're going to take it the
minute you get offered it
what are your plans uh i'm probably not
going to take it the minute i get
offered it
um but you know look i think that the
vaccine being
created on this really fast timeline
tells us a couple of things one
obviously this was a global priority for
a lot of different companies and
governments
and organizations two this is the beauty
of capitalism
is we just watched uh some of our
smartest
uh healthcare-focused organizations
create a vaccine in record time
and so i think it's just again a
reiteration that capitalism works and we
should continue to support
um you know private businesses and small
businesses
but i also think that what we're going
to see is an explosion of pent-up demand
people want to go travel they want to go
see their friends they want to go back
into restaurants they want to go do the
things
that they enjoyed doing beforehand most
people have been pretty smart they
haven't done that stuff during this
pandemic they've tried to wear your mask
they socially distance stay at home
all the things that people have asked of
them but i do think that once the
vaccine is
distributed in a pervasive way you're
going to see people run out to go do all
that stuff and so
you know while we've weathered this kind
of downturn uh
in terms of commerce and economic growth
and things like that
i do think we are going to see this
explosion which is a great opportunity
for a lot of businesses
uh and so to be fun to watch so if you
had to think about that from an
investment thesis i mean i get the sense
you want to see a few hundred thousand
people
take the vaccine first and see what
happens to them is that really what
you're saying when you wouldn't take it
if offered it today
i mean technically you could be offered
this today and you wouldn't take it
because you want to see more outcomes or
what's the reasoning to that because
right now there's stats out there
that i find very scary up to 30 percent
of the population doesn't want to take
the vaccine in some constituencies
50 percent doesn't want to take it and
the point of a vaccine is to inoculate
as many of the herd as you can
we call ourselves the herd for the
biological reasons of getting hurt
immunity
but the idea being that if we could get
everybody vaccinated tomorrow morning
this pandemic would be over
in a couple of months but that's not
what's going to happen we're going to
have some large percentages of
certain verticals of the population
saying now i don't want to do it for
this reason for that reason whatever it
is
and when you do that with a vaccine you
give it a very long
tail so to the extent that people listen
to you pomp
what advice would you give them about
the timing of this vaccine i'm trying to
nail you down
on exactly what you think on that yeah i
think as a society what we're going
through an exercise of is priority
right and so i happen to be very lucky
i'm a 32 year old young guy who's
healthy i have no pre-existing
conditions
i live a relatively kind of insulated
life in terms of
um you know i've done everything that
i'm supposed to do i've gotten my covid
test i'm negative kind of everything
that i'm supposed to do
and so the vaccines that we do have i
think are going to first be given to
our healthcare workers to those that
work inside of the nursing homes things
like that so i actually don't think that
most young people are going to be
offered
the vaccine um you know for sure in the
first couple of weeks if not the first
couple of months
it really just comes down to
prioritization right there's people
frankly who need it way worse than i do
uh
and i'm fortunate for that but but also
i think that it's important that we kind
of prioritize
certain types of people the second thing
then comes down to
um you know there's a lot of unknowns
here right and i think that's where
you're getting at you know when they ask
people will you take the vaccine will
you not
uh i think people are just scared
frankly they don't have enough
information and so
you know if i was in charge of the
vaccine campaign if you will
i think the number one thing that you
can do is not you know hey i'm gonna
take the vaccine
publicly right which we've seen some
elected leaders say that they're going
to do
instead it's educate people explain hey
here's how the virus works here's why
the vaccine works here's what's going to
happen here's what the side effects are
and then give people choice right
i definitely don't think we want to be
in a world where the government is
mandating or making it illegal not to
force you to put something in your body
but at the same time i generally think
that most people are rational actors and
if you explain to them
what the problem is and what the
potential solution and the risk
associated with that solution is
they usually end up taking the rational
choice and in this case
i think getting a vaccinated society can
be a very beneficial thing and so it's
just
don't mandate it don't force it on
people but if you educate people i think
that that number
30 or 50 percent will come way down and
so that's the the kind of body of work
ahead for uh
for governments and these organizations
here's what i see happening though
as we roll out this vaccine with the
passport system i mean you're going to
go into your provider or a pharmacy
take the vaccine you're going to book
your appointment through an app whether
it be cvs walgreens or anybody else
and then when you get your second dose
20 plus days later
you're going to be issued a digital and
a physical passport now let's say i'm a
private sector operator
i have a restaurant i'm running an
airline i have a sports arena
i have a bowling alley i want people
with passports
i don't want to be liable for passing
the vaccine from one to another i don't
want people getting sick in my facility
from my grid of reasons i want all my
employees to have a passport and if you
come to the door and ask to get on my
airline
or come into my restaurant or my bowling
alley or my sports arena
i'm going to say sorry no passport no
tiki
i think that's a way that the private
sector is going to react to this
ever-growing inoculation because it
mitigates
risk and in all things risk mitigation
is the path of least resistance
now that's not mandated by the
government the scenario i just described
to you
but it's a highly likely outcome because
why in the world would i want people on
an airline if i ran an airline to have
one super spreader at the front getting
everybody sick
regardless what people say about the how
the air is transferred around the
aircraft or the airport or the
restaurant whatever it is
do you think that's going to cause any
problems in a sort of have and have
not scenario in america over the next
two years
yeah i mean you can very quickly see why
this gets politicized right it's
basically you get into the ideological
kind of camps of
um private businesses are private and
they're allowed to do whatever they want
uh and then other people who believe
that humans have certain rights and
uh they should be allowed to kind of
prevail over small business
i think what you're going to see is
exactly what you described
there will definitely be businesses i
think even like a ticketmaster and maybe
a couple of others have already said
that their intention is that you will
have to uh be vaccinated or have a
negative test
so it might not just be the vaccine but
they'll have some kind of requirement
for you to participate or attend any of
their venues
and so i think you'll definitely see
more and more businesses doing that um
and where i think the government's going
to be in a very weird situation
is uh one do they encourage this or do
they
deter it right and ultimately there will
be cases where
uh people sue whether it's a business a
government or whatever
on constitutional basis and the courts
will decide i don't i don't think i'm
going to have the answer i don't think
you're going to have the answer
but a court will decide kind of what's
legal and what's not legal
but i do think that we need to be very
very careful here because this is a
slippery slope when it comes to
it's one thing to mitigate risk for your
business it's another when we start
labeling people based on medical history
right
and so there's all kinds of um
suggestions i've seen
literally like you should label
something on your clothing
or on a mask or you should have a
digital passport
on your phone that sounds a little scary
to me because you start to get into a
world where like
we've seen populations separate haves
and have-nots with labels in the past
uh and that usually hasn't turned out so
well and so i think that we've got to be
smart
uh we don't want to put people at a
higher risk but at the same time we also
have to understand that we
can't violate individuals um kind of
personal liberty and individual freedoms
uh as we pursue um you know really
making the
well here's a problem with what you just
said and i'd like to address it
when you give someone an individual
right not to disclose whether they've
been vaccinated or not
or given the right not to vaccinate at
all which is definitely going to happen
in america it may not happen in other
countries but you also give them the
right
to get other people sick and that is a
big big issue for a vaccine that doesn't
understand
race or color or economic status it
simply moves from one person to another
and the outcome for some percentage of
them is a horrible death
in a plastic tent alone and i would
think at some point people are going to
say and this probably happens sometime
next fall we have to finish off this
inoculation and i don't care if it
treads on your rights
i don't want to die and that is where
we're going to test a whole new theory
about public health there's no question
about it and i don't know the outcome of
it you may be right
but i know with certainty having waited
this long sequestering myself
sounds like you're doing the same thing
changing my lifestyle in ways i would
have never anticipated
and i'm really getting sick of it i
don't care how nice it is wherever
i am i like to go out i haven't been to
a restaurant since march 7th
or flown on a commercial aircraft since
then and i want to
and i guess the reason i can't and won't
be able to
is somebody maybe you pomp won't get
vaccinated
and that really pisses me off and i
think to myself wait a second
where are my rights in that scenario
yeah and look this has been kind of the
entire
um you know the entire situation around
the
vaccine and the pandemic i think has
really brought
this exact debate to the forefront and
you know
there's a lot of conversation i think
that's always like black and white
everyone wants to go to the extremes
it's
open the economy um and the hospitals
get overrun or vice versa
close the economy and everyone will be
okay and
you and i know that you know in business
or in life most things aren't black and
white
and so what i think that we're starting
to see now is a conversation around
nuance and how do we find these nuanced
uh kind of solutions and so one thing
for sure is
there is a public health crisis right
there are a lot of people getting sick
with
sick with something it abnormally
affects a certain population other
rather than
others and so there's people now that
are starting to say things like well
wait a second
if you are old if you are sick or you
are scared right just because a lot of
people forget like the psychological
fear of this is takes a toll on people
like you don't actually have to be old
or have to be sick already or have
pre-existing conditions
to just fear it and so if you are in
those buckets we should
protect those people aggressively and
whether that is
keeping them inside providing them with
government stimulus there's all kinds of
things we can do to protect that
population
but i also think at the same time as
we're protecting that population
we have to be weary that we're not also
violating
the rights of an entire other part of
the population right and i've got a
unique view on this because i've spent
so much time
internationally i served in the united
states army overseas did all these
different things where
i saw kind of the end of where this goes
if all of a sudden you start telling
people that they have to do things right
and that's why i go back to it's not
that i don't think people should
get the vaccine it's not that i don't
think people should take the public
health crisis seriously i actually think
that's exactly what they should do right
um but i do think that we've got to be
careful about how we do it
and i don't think government mandates
the right way to go and it sounds like
actually
we agree on this which is uh there's
there's kind of
softer ways of doing it right so for
example if private businesses all start
to say hey you can't
come in my private business unless
you've got the vaccine well
they have the same right that the
individual does the individual has the
right not to take the vaccine
but the private business has the right
to refuse you service
and what you do is you build social
pressure right if you want to go out to
restaurants if you want to go do things
then you got to have the vaccine and so
i think that kind of the free market or
natural market will
really push people and my guess is a
majority of people have taken the
vaccine
i don't know 12 18 months from now so
however long it takes to get the
distribution and kind of get it in
people's hands and have access to it
i do think majority of people will take
it um but but i think that it's just the
the way that we go about it is important
um and you know look at the end of the
day there's a lot of people who've
gotten sick there's a lot of people who
have died
and that's not okay and i agree with you
that we've got to be
careful about allowing frankly stupidity
or the uneducated
to just go around and spread a virus but
i think that there's kind of this
in-between that doesn't exist on the
extremes
i want to talk about some other sectors
music and the arts i'm an investor in
that space
in different places different things in
hip-hop
well i'm going to ask you about that
think about what's happened
to a new artist emerging during this
last
year when you're breaking a new act
the best thing you can do is go to a
city like miami or chicago or l.a or new
york
and hit the streets in terms of getting
into small clubs getting a buzz going
getting people to see you
live it's different than a digital
splurge you know it's just a different
feeling you look at acts
for years and years and decades and
decades it started in clubs and hit the
road and
met with their fans that's a different
trajectory you can't do that anymore and
you
probably won't be able to do it for
maybe another year maybe longer maybe
you know depending what happens to what
we just discussed about passports and
stuff
how do you think a young artist today
that smoking hot should address
getting out there and making a living
when the only option they have
is yet another attempt on youtube or on
instagram to get someone to watch them
yeah what we got to remember is all of
these creators whether they're a
musician a content creator or whatever
they're just entrepreneurs right they're
trying to build a business and that
business is to go get customers
uh to give them money whether it's
through streaming platforms
in-person at concerts buy merchandise
buy their music whatever it is
and i think what we've seen specifically
around musicians is there's been a
number of musicians
who have figured out through these
digital platforms how to
kind of attach their music to viral
moments and so
um there's this story of lil nas x which
is a uh
a guy in kind of the hip-hop space and
what he did was
he would basically look for memes or
gifs and kind of short videos that were
going viral on platforms
he would download them he would put his
music over top of them and then he would
basically re-upload them
and he was trying to basically attach
his music to these viral moments
and what ended up happening is one of
them worked took off and now he's one of
the biggest stars in the world
and so i think that whether it's kind of
the memes on a twitter a reddit a
facebook
or it's simply trying to get your song
to be the background music of the next
tick-tock dance that kind of sweeps the
world
um you know over then i think that's a
way to again get your
work in front of eyeballs that's very
different than going from club to club
in new york city trying to build buzz
but there's advantages to it as well so
you don't maybe you don't get the human
connection that you would playing in
front of
you know 100 people and kind of them
getting to see the live energy
but it's a way to get in front of way
more people much more efficiently
cheaper and faster
and so i don't think that there's a
single answer here i think that there's
going to be tons of musicians once we
can get out of this pandemic that will
go back into
clubs and arenas and venues and they're
going to do great
kind of employing that old playbook that
playbook that's worked for decades and
decades and decades
but there is this new class of creators
and musicians
and entertainers that have figured out
these digital platforms and and you see
these success stories
and you start to wonder maybe actually
the solution moving forward
isn't either or instead it's both and i
think that's what we're going to see
kind of into 2021 and beyond
is people understanding i still need the
human connection by playing in front of
people and them seeing kind of the live
energy
but i also need to be very savvy when it
comes to the digital platforms
and whoever can kind of crack both of
those at the same time is likely to be
the next mega star
well i wonder if that isn't exactly the
same for business any business because
the genie's out of the bottle on digital
i used to say to kids going into college
and racking up college debt
60 80 000 bucks if you want a short
guaranteed job
engineering's number one engineering is
number two in engineering is number
three
i don't feel that way anymore after this
last year because so much of what i
spend on now supporting all my
businesses
is support of their digital strategy
which means copywriters
editors videographers graphic artists
all kinds of technology around editing
and adding to you know
to presentation skills is where i spend
a ton of money that i didn't spend only
two years ago
and so i'm thinking now there's a
resurgence in kind of a very unusual way
to go back there's no starving artists
if you're good
at any of those skills you ain't
starving anymore because the demand for
your skills corporately
and for individuals and for artists and
for businesses and for restaurants for
any sector you're talking about
is to be able to tell a story in 19
seconds 29 seconds 59 seconds
and that i i don't think is ever going
to change
and so we have accelerated digitization
you're part of that
you're part of that whole story the fact
that you've garnered an audience that
listens to you on this stuff is because
of that exact trend
i don't think it's going to change i
don't think your strategy is going to
change
you're not going to be playing any new
york clubs you don't have to you can
reach out to people around the world
every day if you wish
so why why isn't it really something now
that
is probably going to change the way we
think about marketing forever
and the way we spend our dollars yeah so
it's definitely changed right and i
think that digital
is the default now but just like the
businesses that
had kind of analog stores or went into
these venues
and analog was the default and they were
good at digital
they thrived in kind of the old world i
think people who are default digital but
figure out how to mix
in the analog in thoughtful ways will
thrive as well and so
a great example is if you're really
really good at the digital platforms as
the musician
and then maybe you go do meet and greets
with fans at a certain city um
or if you are a entrepreneur and you're
really good at digital but basically you
go and you do a pop-up in your local
shopping center or at a farmer's market
or something like that
and then even if you look at people who
kind of do content creation right so if
i was to go
to a city let's say that i went to st
louis missouri and i tweeted out and i
said hey i'm going to do a live podcast
if you'd like to come
and listen to me do a podcast uh you can
buy a ticket to it there's a lot of
people who probably would buy a ticket
and come and watch
now i'm not going to go do that every
single day and so i think it's more
digital as default and the analog stuff
ends up being really thoughtful
special experiences and allows you to
connect with
your audience your customer base in a
new unique way
but really what's new again is old again
and it's just a repeat of what we
already had
it's just that digital is the majority
of the time and the energy and the money
spent
rather than analog it gives me an idea
pump i should have done this in an
amphitheater and sold tickets
big screen of you big screen of me i
mean how did i leave i would
you and i could sell out madison square
garden if we did enough promotion
how did we leave that on the table all
right i want to end with how i always
end
i want to give you a chance to just
describe three stocks that you would buy
at the beginning of the year and hold
for 12 months
for next year any investments they can
be they don't have to be stocks it could
be anything you want
three things that you would put your
money into for the next 12 months
yeah that's a great question um i would
say that
one for sure is i think that we're going
to see
a lot of fintech kind of continue the
trend that it has
and explode in that area you've probably
got square as the leader i think in
terms of just
highly innovative company that really
understands uh technology
and finance is pulling off global
expansion and it's also operating in the
legacy world
of kind of more traditional finance and
this new world of bitcoin and crypto
so i think square is uh kind of a leader
that's pick number one
square luckily i own that already what's
next
two is i think that you're going to see
kind of these platform commerce
businesses do very well
and so there's a whole bunch of
different ways to play them uh you could
just go
with simple amazon right and kind of get
part of their their commerce business
and everything else
uh you could go to a shopify kind of arm
the rebels
uh and really the the anti-amazon if you
will of some degree
uh or even things like uh we commerce is
a uh buddy of mine andrew wilkinson
uh recently put into the public markets
via let's talk about ecommerce he
i did the show with him today halftime
report he came on talked about his
raise his strategy he's going to try and
be the next generation berkshire
hathaway that was his pitch
and he's going to identify companies
living on an island in canada somewhere
which i found intriguing
which really signals how you can do this
digitally from wherever you
are he was very good he took a real
grilling from the crew
and he came out on top i thought good
guy what what do you what do you
what do you think about his he's now
public he went public
on a canadian exchange this morning you
think he's a good buy is that your pick
or would you go
shopify directly or amazon yeah so the
reason why
uh ecommerce is so interesting is one
again you are
investing in the people behind these
companies and their capital allocation
decisions
uh and their abilities right there's a
lot of things that can change as we saw
in 2020
and if you were backing companies that
had great operators they probably did
pretty well
if you were backing companies that
didn't have such great operators uh then
they didn't do so well
and so i always look at yes the
fundamentals of the business make sense
but i like to look at who the person is
at running the company and do i trust
them
uh with the task of growing my wealth
growing my capital
and i think andrew and the entire team
there uh is really world class they've
proven this over and over and over again
uh and so for uh for a kid that
basically started a uh
a design studio uh from canada a number
of years ago to uh to today is pretty
impressive so i i so
so your investment premise on that
platform is he helps to find
operational winners and you're investing
with their head
not having any headwind you've got great
operators so you've got the tailwind
behind them
and you have a portfolio you're
diversifying your wrist that's the
investment thesis
yeah it's the same thing like any
private equity type firm would do right
they look for companies that they can
buy
uh at good prices so you're betting that
andrew can find winners it's the same
way you would bet on ackman to find
private companies to take public same
idea right
exactly okay you got one more and i like
your premise
because i'm a huge shareholder in
shopify
why because i buy all their licenses for
all my companies i mean we use that
platform
almost exclusively outside of amazon and
i believe that
you know we're going to try and replace
as much retail as we can and sell direct
and get the full margin
one more investment idea one more
investment thesis what do you like
yeah so i love to operate at the fringes
of society i look for the
contrarian idea that will be con become
consensus over the next you know 12 to
24 months
and uh the two areas that i'm going to
kind of lump together
as a single idea is psychedelics and
bitcoin
i think that there's a whole bunch of
different ways you can play this but
from my perspective
both of those are contrarian ideas and
especially have been for the last two or
three years
and they are just now hitting the
inflection point where they are about to
become consensus ideas
um and so the psychedelic space
individual names i'm not as familiar
with i know there's field trip and a
couple of others
i don't know if there's like an index
that you could buy there but when it
comes to bitcoin
uh one of the interesting companies is
there's a company microstrategy that
basically
uh you know michael saylor the ceo there
has taken
85 plus percent of his balance sheet
he's bought bitcoin he's now raised
about 600 650 million dollars in debt to
buy more bitcoin
and he's almost backed himself into like
a pseudo uh bitcoin etf to some degree
right he's got all this bitcoin exposure
uh and so the stock has done very well
in 2020 i think it'll continue to do
well
as bitcoin continues to do well and so
those two areas are really interesting
to me but just along the theme of
go to the edges of society find a
contrarian idea that'll become consensus
over the next 12 to 24 months
and i think both psychedelics and
bitcoin fit that fit that bill
well it's interesting i mean i've been
you know talking to you for
a bit about bitcoin for over a year so
you're getting me
you know me sort of tenderized like a
piece of veal before it becomes a
scallopini on it
um but i think i'm ahead of you on
psychedelics i was a very early investor
in mind med
and that's gone from a nascent company
to over a billion market cap in a matter
of months
because you're right thematically the
whole sector is being re-explored as
medicine
not recreational drugs the idea that you
can help people
uh with depression or opioid addiction
or these massive maladies that afflict
whole societies and solve it with a drug
that we've ignored since the 60s
lsd or mda or you know 18mc these
different molecules i'm
i'm into that i've been an investor in
that i'm i'm a huge advocate for the
sector
and we don't yet know the outcomes but
it's nasa we're starting the fda
trial stage one trade stage two but
that's interesting that you would have
identified that as well and no it isn't
indexed yet you know i am an indexer and
there is no index
for psychedelics it's too early but
there's many companies and if anybody's
going to index it
i'm going to take a shot at it one day
but i've got to get more companies
there's just not enough diversification
yet
and that's the key if you like that
video wait you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe